♪♪
I'm sorry, Amy.
You're allergic
to alcohol.
You can never have another drink
for the rest of your life.
Second opinion.
( man )
You can never have
another drink.
You're allergic
to alcohol.
Blah, blah, blah, if Peyton
stays healthy, blah, blah, blah.
He's the star,
blah, blah, blah.
But Eli,
Backbone blah,
blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah, Rogers and
Brady won the blah, blah, blah.
Zone one "D," bro,
blah, blah, blah.
Sport.
Sport, sport
sport, sport...
sport,
sport, Amy,
sport, sport, Amy...
( man )
You're allergic to alcohol.
You can never have another
drink.
Yiling went
back to China.
I do your bikini
area today.
Oh... oh...
( speaking foreign language )
It looks like inside of
barbershop vacuum.
( whimpering )
Hate you.
Everyone hates you!
( sobbing )
( man )
You can never
have another drink...
( woman )
Give me more wax!
Blah, blah, blah,
Madison for a girl,
Hunter for a boy,
blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah,
push present,
blah, blah, blah?
Oh, blah, blah,
Ann Taylor Loft, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah,
natural birth,
blah, blah, blah.
( screaming )
( panting )
♪♪
Zero fat?
Zero calories?
And who do we have here?
( woman on PA )
Excuse me, shoppers.
We will now play the
entire soundtrack
to "Rent" and"Newsies."
Also, Amy is the prettiest
customer
we've ever had in here,
and Hilary Duff is someone
we've had in here.
( whimpering )
Amy, it's me, Ron,
your handsome
ex-boyfriend.
This is my
fiancée, Karen.
We're getting married.
( choir )
♪ And you will see ♪
♪ That Newsboys
sell the paper ♪
Newsboys!
Yes.
One puppy for
every Newsie.